so I recently watched a movie called the
killing of the sacred deer and the
premise seemed very familiar to me but I
couldn't exactly put my finger on why
when I looked into it further the basis
of the movie is indeed rooted in Greek
mythology and the story of Iphigenia and
the sacred deer the story takes place
during the Trojan War King Agamemnon had
angered the goddess Artemis when he
killed one of her sacred deer at the
time the Greek army were preparing to
set sail for Troy an in retaliation
Artemis stopped all the winds making it
so Agamemnon and his army could not set
sail the king was informed in order to
appease Artemis he would have to
sacrifice his daughter Iphigenia
Agamemnon was reluctant at first but
with the pressure of the war he had no
other choice but to accept Artemis as
demands in order for if a denier to go
willingly he lied to his daughter and
his wife telling them that she was to
marry Achilles before they left her Troy
the family happy with the agreement
travelled to Port Alice
only to find out the horrible truth upon
her Ivan Achilles unaware of the
situation attempted to stop the
sacrifice but if a Jenaya had already
decided that she would sacrifice herself
willingly
upon scene if a deniers willingness to
atone for a sin that was not her own
artemis substituted Iphigenia for a deer
the early witness to this was the seer
Calchas who told no one if a denial was
brought to the city of taurus where she
would become a priestess in Artemis's
temple several years later our easties
if a deniers brother killed his mother
and her lover when he caught them he was
being hunted by the ironies of the
Furies because he had just committed
matricide he fled to Taurus in the hopes
that he would be able to seek refuge
when he arrived he was captured by the
locals and brought to a fat Jenaya
believing his sister was dead he did not
recognize her eventually if Adonai
explained the truth to her brother and
the two managed to escape the city
returned into Greece where if a denial
would continue to serve as priestess in
Artemis's temple in this tale if a
denier is essentially a scapegoat the
collateral damage in a conflict between
her father and the gods
it was pretty commonplace in Greek
mythology for the gods to demand
retribution against the acts of men was
an almost eye for an iron mentality
Artemis could have easily killed
Agamemnon but she would rather make an
example of him in all likelihood the
sacrifice would have gone ahead to teach
Agamemnon a lesson and established the
gods authority over men it wasn't until
artemis saw how willing if a denial was
to pay the price for her father's
actions that she decided if a Jedi as
purity and innocence would make for a
perfect priestess the killing of a
sacred deer is not a fast paced movie
and it's definitely not for everyone but
it's nice to see Greek mythology is
still influenced in movies today
[Music]
[Music]